know the words of the song you guys want
to
[Applause]
sing this is Hans Kim
everybody this is Hans Kim this is hot
cam
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's good to be here
love how cold it is right now cuz now we
all have Asian
dicks
I love how Texans never honk they'll be
like why would I honk at this guy just
cuz he's texting at a green light that's
what my gun is
for it kind of scares me when I tell
Texans that I bought a gun for the first
time they're like
good let the games
begin I went back to Seattle recently
very tough to be from Seattle my
hometown because all of my friends have
transitioned and now I have to remember
two sets of
names all right that should be about 60
seconds right all right yeah 55 seconds
from Hans Kim I love
it all right jet lag Red Band Waits
until the initial Applause die out he
waits until you start talking so
whatever you're trying to milk over
there I don't know what's going on but
we got through it how about one more
time for Hans Kim
everybody cold Asian dicks checks out
absolutely the honking thing is a weird
thing here in Texas that is a thing I
remember when I first got here I was
like at I was doing something I was at a
hotel or something and somebody wouldn't
move I was like dropping somebody off
and a car would move and I go beep beep
and some exactly that's a it's the horn
on my car thank you red ban uh this show
is so stupid there you go thank okay
thank you yes that's my Corvette engine
and my horn so I start the car and it
goes and then I go all
right and some lady was like we don't
honk here in Texas and I'm like what and
and I I didn't know what to I didn't
know how to respond to that but I've
realized since then people really don't
honk do you guys know about this yeah
this [__] guy said yeah quick was
that
you you born and raised in Texas why do
you think that is that it's a Texas
thing not to honk courtesy courtesy what
a bunch of homos Jesus courtesy how
about you C how about you Curtis curly
get the [__] out of my way courteously
courteously what the [__] oh [__]
marijuana um you ever heard of something
so crazy no hon no it sounds gay yeah
that's what I'm saying it sounds like
the only time you really hear the the
horn is coming off the guy's forehead
when he's going down on you that is true
you know what that sounds like it's okay
that is all right so Hans how's it going
what else is going on with you I'm doing
good um you know my I [__] the
stripper in a broom closet um that is
true back in the day the rumor is you
got [__] by a stripper in a broom
closet yeah can you explain so the Dave
understands what it's like having sex
with Hans because Greg said that you got
[__] and I kind of agree with that uh
can you explain yeah well I agree with
Dave as well I did not consent for a lot
of it
uh she was very forceful she's like this
is going to happen and there's a guy
that can watch us while we're doing it
too and I was like I'm good on the guy
yeah they say you never forget the first
time you get
pegged no don't be
judgmental yeah there you go honking of
the horn so I didn't I don't think I
remember that part she invited a guy to
come into the broom closet with you it
was her boyfriend that's a lot that's a
tight squeeze not her vagina but the
closet anybody that would [__] you it's
probably like throwing a [__] ramen
noodle into a bowl you know what I mean
it's just a lot of extra space there
what is your dick of vagina ratio Hans
I've never I don't think I've asked you
that I have one dick and I'm a huge
[__] so there you go
there you go
perfect um I love it what else is going
on enough about the past what about this
week Hans I went to the Renaissance
Festival with my
girlfriend
um those of you that don't know there is
an awesome human being that comes to
every show and it's fun to hear what he
laughs at uh it's not necessarily
punchline type of stuff but our friend
Chief here when you said I went to a
Renaissance but he just started cracking
up it's like he can foresee what's about
to happen tell us more about you at this
Renaissance Festival Hans how did you
fit in I've never seen an Asian person
at a I've never gone to a Renaissance
Festival but I've never imagined an
Asian person being there what are you
doing there are you just like dressed up
like gangas Khan or something like that
just mauling people what's happening I
was just trying to fit in you know
wearing my western clothing my uh my
peasants European white white passing
clothes um uhhuh and I uh I had a great
time drank a lot of meat they have
straws and meat I was just sipping it
and then I got really [__] up on the
on the white man's juice and uh ah back
to the broom closet we
go the white man's
juice what would the Asian man's juice
us be probably sake or uh Soju or maybe
even just like you know Ox milk Soju is
that what Soju what is that is that when
somebody doesn't leave a tip at a
restaurant hey hey hey Tony's first Soju
joke everybody so
Soju 5%
so
that's really
[Laughter]
scky what was the third one Ox juice
what did you say Ox milk Ox milk Ox milk
what the [__] is Ox milk uh the milk of
an
ox or a water I think that's bull sperm
isn't it yeah I've been milking the
males on accident how do you milk an ox
can you show us how you milk an ox
you're Asian oh Jesus Jus Christ holy
[__] hansy boy my dear dear Hans Kim
is's a wild animal how's your
relationship going my girlfriend is
great she is uh you know starting fewer
fights with me now um like what was it
like a can I know we never plan any of
these interviews so I don't want to get
you in trouble but can you give us an
example of what a fight was this
week uh well um maybe it was bringing
her to a Renaissance Fair where they're
known to rape the women
I I was uh actually on this show I
actually said that I wanted to have a
threesome with their friend and she
really didn't think that was a cool
thing to
say right that'll do it
yeah yeah so like uh did it last long do
your fights last long do you solve them
quickly we solve them pretty quickly I
usually try to end it with a little sex
I feel like that
helps that's true that's true okay you
guys you guys have a lot of sex am I
correct yeah um we had a lot of sex um
but like I took her to Tacoma this
weekend and we didn't really have that
much sex we uh we only had one and a
half sex oh one and a half sex explain
to us and the people listening around
the world what what counts for half a
sex that's when uh I cuddle her and then
with this hand I jerk off onto her oh oh
wow ooh the old cuddle and puddle the
old
[__] the old [__] Ox milk over
here the old
[__] the old [__] all right
guys Han so much fun way to get
tonight's show started is there anything
I'm missing anything you want to say um
I had a great time at the Renaissance
Festival uh what did they let you in for
free they're like just give us a shout
out dude dude you're good come on in
come on in
bro we need some promos at the
Renaissance a shout out to every
Renaissance Festival you'll never hear
that on like a black radio station where
they actually give shout outs like yo yo
yo shout out to my [__] Uncle Char
Char and the Renaissance Festival on
Martin Luther King Drive did you do
stand up at the festival no I I was just
I was just a peasant oh just walking
around you weren't the Court Jester no
I I wish that was some white guy yeah
wow amazing there was there a court
jester yeah there was a whole show they
were uh swallowing swords and you know
doing all that stuff enough about your
girlfriend uh knives all right we love
you Hans way to get it started there he
goes a new minute from the legendary
regular Hans
Kim okay here we go let's keep it moving
here it's another
name